foreign
to this meeting of the council
our last meeting together
I am councilor Catherine Grandin
chairman of baber District Council and I
will be carrying this meeting today
my first of all remind you of some of
our domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it's safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silence
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of these
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council member of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now move on to the agenda
item one a public use for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies from Kansas heirs Gould Mabry
hardacre and Creswell
thank you item two Declarations of
Interest by councilors are there any
Declarations of Interest
thank you no Declarations of Interest
item three
paper BC
2245 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 20th February 2023 for
accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
thank you could I have a proposer please
Simon Barrett thank
you thanks seconder John Hinton thank
you
we'll do a show of hands
all those in favor
thank you that is carried
item four
paper BC 2246
announcements from the chairman and
leader
first of all I refer you to paper
bc2246 for noting and then I'd just like
to say a few words
well counselors we are reaching the end
of our term with elections approaching
some of us may not see each other again
in this chamber
this is where I insert a sad emoji
I think we can all acknowledge our term
has been a momentous one
as an intake of 2019 we have experienced
a term that no other baber counselors
have faced
tomorrow will Mark three years since
Boris Johnson's announcement of the
first lockdown
an occasion that most people are likely
to have indelibly imprinted on their
mind
apart from the effects of the illness
itself
covert led to a whole new way of working
one that progressed to ongoing changes
in the way that baber operates
those new methods have become our
current Norm
but you remember the difficulties
officers and councilors experienced
initially
I recall minutes before the first full
Council teams meeting
frantic calls to Mandy as counselors
couldn't work out how to access the
system
or their Wi-Fi dropped out and Robert
Carmichael was wrecking his brains
working out the new tech
seems so simple now
apart from this aspect of working
differently we dealt with working solely
from home and helped our residents cope
with everything that covid brought them
we encountered fear and hope we managed
grants and payments
Road barriers
cues for vaccinations
bringing raw sleepers undercover and so
much more
and of course many of us had to deal
with sickness
and sometimes worse
personally and in our communities
and through it all we showed great
resilience
and our normal work continued alongside
emergency measures
and gradually gradually Council meetings
and Council life got back to normal
by Western Park
work from home is typical office space
is halved and we only all bump into each
other at full Council meetings
another important antihistoric event
happened during our term
the third passing of her majesty the
queen
oh Queen
I think many of us felt quite emotional
and it was reflected in this chamber
we have presided over many other huge
changes and challenges during this term
of course now we are facing a cost of
living crisis
there will be aspects of this term that
we will feel proud of
others where we all think we should have
done more or acted differently
but that's politics
it has truly been an honor and privilege
to bring chairman of Bieber District
Council
I've enjoyed every minute of it
especially having the opportunity to
represent the council at Civic events
think you can probably tell how much I
have valued and enjoy enjoyed being
chairman
thank you for giving me the opportunity
I have a refreshed wardrobe
and it has been a pleasure meeting other
Civic dignitaries and exchanging views
and assisting each other and I have
enjoyed sharing these meetings
I hope you consider that I have given
you a fair opportunity to speak in this
chamber
of course there is the old adage that
you can't please all the people all of
the time
and there are good governance reasons if
I have closed you down
I have been fortunate to have sat in
this chair for the metaphorical care for
three out of the four years of this term
partly due to the problems of covid
I thank and congratulate cancer Adrian
Osborne for the excellent job that he
accomplished while he was chairman last
year
it was not always easy for him as he too
was experiencing the tail end of the
restrictions brought on by covid
I'm very grateful for the support of all
our fantastic officers who have
supported our Council meetings and who
has who have supported us in our work in
the district to enable us to carry out
our work in our community
I would like to especially thank John
Robinson and my Civic officer Karen
Sayer
thank you to all our officers
I would like to say thank you to all my
fellow councilors
thank you for your mostly good behavior
for those voting me into this role
for your support and Care during my
illness
and to those of you who attended my
fundraising function
and to all of you for helping me to
raise over eleven thousand pounds for
the blossom appeal
whatever your future plans you'll be
invited to the annual meeting in May
after the annual meeting members are
invited to a presentation of photos
Awards and certificates and there'll be
some refreshments
I wish the best of luck to all of you
who are standing in the forthcoming
elections
and a happy and well deserved return to
civvy Street for those not returning
thank you
thank you thank you
I would now like to invite councilor
Ward to make his announcements
thank you chairman um I don't know how
I'm going to follow that that was pretty
good thank you
so last month I remember reminded
members about our end of term report and
I thought that this month as it is the
last council meeting before the election
that I take the opportunity to talk
about what I think have been the
highlights of the past four years
as the chairman has eloquently described
it has been a very different and unusual
term characterized by the changes in the
way we work that were imposed by covid
which have now been embedded in agile
and flexible work patterns
this has been supported by the recently
open new gold floor plate design
our officers Rose to the challenge of
covert magnificently to support our
businesses
but also our communities and vulnerable
residents including the homeless and
rough sleepers
as we emotion covid our economic
development team put together a very
comprehensive and successful economic
recovery plan covering Town Center
regeneration business support and skills
development I have to say for me this
has been one of the best things this
Council has done in my time as a
counselor
didn't just include things that our two
councils have done on our own but
crucially it also linked with wider
County initiatives from Suffolk public
sector leaders and the LEP
over the past four years we've built or
bought about 180 Newcastle houses across
the district and our HRA business plan
commits us to further increases in our
stock to help meet the affordable
housing requirements of the joint local
plan
local plan the part one modifications
required by the inspectors have been
completed and are now up for
consultation
this means part one will be ready for
Council to adopt towards the end of the
summer
meanwhile work requested by the
inspectors for part two has started
our carbon reduction management plan by
A diversity action plan are starting to
deliver a real impact on improving the
environment
moving from diesel to HBO for our
vehicle Fleet and the installation of
solar panels on our Leisure centers and
on on carports in their car parks and
now delivering significant reductions in
the carbon and emissions of the two
councils as well as generating a
substantial proportion of the
electricity used by the Leisure centers
we have completed a groundbreaking tree
canopy survey so that we now know where
to target new tree and hezero planting
for maximum benefit
I just want to list several other
highlights It Is by no means an
exhaustive list but it does represent
the breadth of what we've been able to
do
on the economic side there's the virtual
High Street Innovation Labs innovate
local and the innovate to elevate
programs
two Innovation Awards events both very
successful and also further events and
competitions for school leavers and and
young adults entering the workforce
a new culture Heritage and visitor
economy strategy
new customer access points digital
improvements with a new website imminent
and also digital skill sessions for
residents
local cycling and walking infrastructure
plan
Hadley commercial workspace project the
new heavy swimming pool refurbishment of
the Kingfisher Leisure Center
communities and well-being strategies
the new combined in-house public realm
service our support for gainsworth's
house and St Peters in Sudbury
the many Community grants and seal
grants that we have made for projects
and groups across the district
and finally of course the cost of living
action plan that we had to rush through
and get into place as a result of the
the turmoil of last year
so a very busy turn which has delivered
a huge amount for our residents however
there are still some unresolved issues
that the new Council and cabinet will
have to address
the further development of our
partnership with mid-suffer being one
parking charges the Regeneration of the
Hamilton Road area of Sudbury
and Building Services and our program of
repairs and energy saving retrofitting
for our Council houses
the new Council term will I'm sure see
significant change in the membership of
the council
these are still difficult times although
as you have heard we have had many
achievements that have helped our
businesses and communities
all the new councilors will have to
Grapple with the ongoing challenge of
how to deliver services with continuing
pressure on funding and costs but they
will inherit a council that is in good
shape to meet that challenge
however however we must remain
responsible and credible and not make
promises that are impossible to deliver
or which which may impair our ability to
deliver
or indeed waste money
finally despite the problems along the
way I want to thank all of you for your
support and allowing me to form two very
effective coalitions it has been
difficult at times but I have enjoyed it
and I am proud of our record
it will be interesting to see how many
of us still will be here when the
Newcastle convenes in May
I would also of course like to thank the
chief executive and the senior
leadership team and officers who have
given me a huge amount of support and
help and encouragement and I think we
are very well
rewarded with the staff that we have
here at Beaver
and finally finally
Council Busby happy birth
he did say 49 I don't believe that
either
thank you Council Ward and happy
birthday Dave
yeah the drinks are on John Legend
so now move on to the agenda
item five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with Council
procedure rules
thank you chair and unreceived
thank you
item six questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure rules
I refer to the question in the tabled
paper and I would like to invite Deborah
Dwyer to ask her question
thank you chair
um I have to say that this is my second
question so it somehow loses a little
bit of context but nevertheless
um I will go ahead with this so it is
now estimated that nearly 60
000 illegal economic migrants arrive on
small boats into the UK the vast
majority of these are adult males under
the age of 40. we don't know anything
about them as they have disposed of any
ID documents before arriving we don't
know who they are they have paid a
trafficking gang for their Journey film
footage shows well-dressed men laughing
and joking making hand signals at
cameras they do not appear to be in
uh Deborah Tire I'm afraid you don't
seem to be reading your question I have
to give it some kind of context here you
have to submit you have to read the
question that you submitted I I
understood that well I understood from
talking to
um the the council office that I would
be able to give some context
um you can if submitted beforehand but
you have to submit everything that
you're going to say to them that's very
disappointing it wouldn't take too long
um I have listened to other people's uh
talking of speeches but however yes on
this occasion on this occasion I would
just ask my question
um
local budgets are under
um enormous strain and there is concern
that an intake of illegal economic
refugees to the area will be given
precedence on local services such as
waiting lists for housing housing
Healthcare and Social Services how will
bayburg Council ensure that the illegal
economic refugees needs are not given
priority
to your question as submitted please
oh that's the one I've got printed
sorry that's that's what I have
um
if you have something different you'll
have to tell me what it is would you
like to just now move to the last part
of your question which is the actual
question now please
ensure that illegal economic migrants
needs are not given priority over the
needs of local people
thank you thank you
um I would like to invite counselor
Glenn Osborne to respond
thank you madam chairman thank you
Deborah dyer for your question we've got
there in the end yeah the localism ACT
2011 brought in local connection rules
which allows the council to protect the
needs of local people regarding housing
this ensures that local residents are
given preference for housing within the
district
beta Council uses several schemes to
ensure that local connection rules
protect the needs of local people
these include a local connection rule
meaning that applicants will be placed
one band below their assessed band if
they do not have a local connection
if applicants claim a location
connection to the district through
family this is defined as a sun daughter
brother sister mother or father aged 18
or over who lives in the scheme area and
has done so for at least five years
checked during the application process
when properties are shortlisted officers
review applications again to ensure that
their circumstances and housing needs
qualify and offer including local
connections
we will continue to work with
communities developers and registered
providers to increase the supply of
housing within the baber area
The Joint local plan underpins these
Healthcare and social Care Fall outside
the scope of our responsibilities these
will fall under the ICB the integrated
care board the NHS and Suffolk County
Council
Osborne
um Deputy do you have a supplementary
question and it has got to be related
yeah yeah so I would just like to to
check whether there wouldn't be any
interference interference from
government in terms of having to to to
take
um
economic
migrants
any pressure from from government in
order to to house
I'm not too sure of the answer for that
one and I feel it would be better under
the circumstances to make sure that
we're absolutely 100 correct in the
answer that I'm giving you that we
provide that via an email if that's okay
okay thank you
thank you councilor Osborne thank you
Deborah's wife
we'll now move to item seven
questions by counselors in accordance
with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
thank you item eight BC
2247 overview and scrutiny committee
report I would like to invite councilor
Hinton to introduce his report councilor
Hinton
foreign
thank you madam chairman
the report is in front of you I must
first of all apologize for the fact that
when I took the job as the chairman of
overview and scrutiny I said I would try
and keep all reports to two sheets of A4
uh three sides here so we're getting
there slowly but it's important that we
tell you tell you as members what has
been going on
the only additions I've got to what is
in front of you are the fact that the
private sector housing enforcement and
civil penalties policy is before it's
canceled tonight
so you'll get your chance to have a look
at that and when it went before cabinet
all of the points that overview and
scrutiny had brought forward were
considered
I would also just say that uh
it mentions in there that I asked for
that an item on public ground should
come before the overview and scrutiny
that came came before the last over the
unscrutiny meeting and they were given a
I won't say a grilling but it was
studied in some detail to make sure that
it was the right thing that we were
doing and we will continue to keep
looking at it to make sure that it's
performing as we would like it to
and lastly I would just say that the
water and sewage
item that this Council referred to
overview in scrutiny after a motion from
councilor Lindsay
we didn't consider it at the last
meeting because there was a request from
angling water that it be deferred to the
next overview and scrutiny meeting for
the simple reason that they're
up-to-date data that's the 2223 data
would not be a fully Consolidated until
the 22nd of April and we felt that it
was important that we had up-to-date
data so that we could give it a a robust
and diligent hearing
how did you take any questions
thank you councilor Hinton any questions
for councilor Hinton regarding overview
and scrutiny
okay no questions so um we'll move on to
the next item on the agenda
um item nine to receive reports from
cabinet members
I would like to invite councilor arthi
to introduce his report cmu1
Cabinet member for planning
thank you chairman
um I've provided a written report for
you which I hope everyone has read you
will see it includes our work on the
seal framework review and the joint
local planning enforcement plan both of
which we will be considering later
at the end of last week you were also
told that we have our joint local plan
part one modifications document agreed
with the inspectors and act consultation
it is two years since we submitted our
plan and I hope you all agree that it is
a relief to get to this stage before
this Council term draws to a close
it has been an interesting and demanding
four years and our work on the jlp has
been particularly challenging
chairman I must thank Tom Barker
together with Rob Hobbs and Phyllis Bell
and the staff in their various teams for
their commitment and support through
some difficult times
thank you and thank you chairman
's
if there are no questions for councilor
arthi
I'll invite him to stand up again
um as he's taking our next item which is
bc2248 community infrastructure Levy
silix friendship framework fifth review
March 2023
so I'd like to invite counselor arthi to
introduce this item and to move the
recommendations councilor arthi
thank you I presume that the last report
was duly noted it was for noting wasn't
it
um so thank you chairman the cell
expenditure framework and communication
strategy were originally agreed and
adopted by both councils in March 2018.
it has been reviewed on a yearly basis
ever since through the work of a joint
member panel and has also been
considered by joint overview and
scrutiny
it was great in October 2022 that it
would be reviewed for a fifth time by
The Joint member panel to ensure it
keeps posts with changing infrastructure
demands and delivery
this report and the recommended changes
are the outcome of that work
the fifth review took place in December
2022 and January 2023
the members on the joint member panel
are listed in paragraph 1.3 of your
report and I thank them for their
involvement
the key changes to both documents are
listed in full in paragraph 4.5
and if I can just run through the cell
expenditure framework firstly
as you will see key changes are around
libraries a clawback facility and a
reduction in the period for quotations
to be held
you will also see the joint member panel
confirmed our position regarding
feasibility studies for district heating
schemes and proposals from businesses
for business purposes
the new one hundred thousand pound limit
is endorsed as is the use of ring fenced
monies first
you will remember the starts taken in
the fourth review which prevented the
use of District sale for Highway
measures
however we are now recommending
including Highway measures which form
part of a walking and cycling project
for an LC whip the local cycling and
walking infrastructure plan
this is an addition to any other Highway
measures that might be delivered
through section 106 or under the section
278 of the highways Act
by continuing with this opportunity for
funding We Believe seal will be a key
component in delivery of LC whip schemes
you will also see that we are asking
that we continue with proactive
approaches for expenditure of District
sale and spending of neighborhood still
to encourage the delivery of
infrastructure projects to support
growth
we're also asking that we keep the cell
expenditure framework under review
we suggest another review which would be
the sixth should occur while spin round
12 is underway in October 2023 so that
any revisions are adopted before bid
round 13 in May 2024
finally we agree The Joint member panel
will will remain to inform that sixth
review
chairman moving on to the sill
expenditure framework communication
strategy
there is a small change proposed to the
way we consult on sill bids
consultation will continue in the agreed
way with the same parties and for the
same 14-day period but sell bids no
longer need to be valid for consultation
to occur
we will also be looking to allow
extensions of time if requested to do so
finally we will continue with three
briefings each year for members and
parishes building on the well-attended
and well-received briefings that were
held in December 2022
I'm asking the council to agree the
changes under the recommendations in
Section 3 of the report they are at 3.1
that baber Council approve the
amendments to the silk expenditure
framework March 2023 as arising from the
fifth review
at appendix a
and the silk expenditure framework
communication strategy March 2023 at
appendix B
3.2 that baby Council agree that the
silk expenditure framework and the silk
expenditure framework communication
strategy be reviewed again whilst bid
round 12 is being considered in October
2023 so that any amended scheme can be
in place before bid around 13 occurs in
May 2024 and at 3.3 that baber agreed
that the joint member panel be retained
to inform that sixth review
chairman on proportions recommendations
and that the production of the yearly
seal calendar for
2023-24 should be agreed by delegated
powers
finally
um
my thanks to the members of the panel
which I've already already expressed and
to Christine Thurlow and her team we've
got Christine and Joe Hobbs hit Joe
Hobbs sorry
Joe Moy here this evening
thank them for guiding us through the
review and if you have any detailed
questions I'm sure that Christine or Joe
will be able to answer them thank you
chairman thank you Council Rossi uh
could I have a second of first please
Council award
um we'll now move to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish have must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
has anyone got any questions
councilor Parker thank you
yeah thank you very much Jeff um just
with regards to the clawback and bear in
mind councilor Arthur I'm a big big fan
of cell I think this is one of the
single best bits of work that Council
has done since 2017 I think we're
looking at something in the order of 18
million pounds that's coming to the
coffers and being distributed through
the framework so big big fan but can you
just um give me some explanation around
the claw back what not necessarily for
for members in the show but for those
that might be watching what's that
actually mean
um in in terms of a residence and and
what was the thinking behind the
clawback why are we introducing that now
and it hasn't been there before
okay thank you
um it was as a result of one particular
bid that we received a large bid um
Consignments when it was it was the
establishment of a befriending scheme
Farm in Lindsay which you were probably
aware of because it was previously in
Essington
there was
um
a concern expressed I suppose that we
had previously offered seal funding
which had been accepted for the
establishment of that befriending scheme
Farm in assington and
a few years later
that
spending if you like was
um
it had been spent um so the
infrastructure that it provided if you
like was no longer going to be there
so
it was possible for some of the funding
that we'd provided for some of the
project costs it was possible for some
of those assets to be trans it but there
was concern expressed about the um the
amount that was involved and the likely
length of
stay if you like of the proposed scheme
in Lindsay so we came up with a clawback
facility which they accepted and that
was that if for any reason
um the assistance that we've given them
prove not to be long term that we could
actually claw back those funds if you're
asking about the specifics of how the
clawback would work which you might be
I'm looking at Christine Thurlow and
hoping that she'll be able to add a
little bit of detail to how that
mechanism would work in the events that
we were seeking to claw back the sill
funds that were awarded
risks associated with offering the money
but felt that there was sufficient funds
available to the befriending scheme in
order to offset those risks
um in terms of taking this forward for
other cases I think the joint member
panel considered that this was an
important principle but would vary
seldom be used because what we try to do
with sill bids is uh reduce all the
risks and make sure that we are landing
a project to take forward thank you
are there any other questions
councilor Melanie Barrett
thank you um just take this opportunity
to ask a bit about
um
how you've considered if you've
considered any examples of applications
that have come forward in the past year
that haven't been successful and whether
you feel that you should
examine those when you're carrying out
this process
to see if
they should have probably been
successful but for some sort of uh sort
of administrative problem with the how
the rules apply you weren't able to
agree them
okay
um I wouldn't know the ones that didn't
get through the process which I think is
what you're asking
um again I'm looking to Christine
um obviously there's a lot of inquiry
goes on beforehand because we have the
cell inquiry process I don't know how
many falls short then and I don't know
how many submit bits and then fall short
because the ones that we consider are
the ones that are moving forward so I
don't know if Christine may be able to
give us some idea what you're really
asking is the ones that fail the process
um
fail but there is a sense that perhaps
they should have been successful because
they are definitely a value to the
community and they are areas where
um the the support should be forthcoming
in some way from the council
there are some that fail and then come
back modified which we can end up
supporting I do know that but if there
are any what I think what you're asking
is are there schemes projects that fall
completely flat
and if they do is it simply because they
don't meet the framework criteria or is
there something else that that leads to
not being supported
um Christine are you sorry oh sorry
sorry I'll just clarify that last point
it's
you're you're constantly reviewing sill
framework
um each year
um is there any any uh value in
examining a failed application and
looking at it with a new lens to say
well should we be tweaking the new
Arrangements
to allow this this failed application to
succeed because it is actually got a lot
of Merit
okay so I think what you're asking is
should the framework include a review of
failed applications basically at least
one okay Christine
thank you
expenditure framework uh one of the key
principles is that we operate a can-do
approach
so for those cases that are submitted as
syllabids which lie outside the
framework because people want more than
a hundred thousand or they don't have
all of their funding agreed we generally
either hold their sill bid in hand while
we negotiate with them uh you know if
it's a community bed and there is a need
to attract more funding in order to land
the project than we would choose one of
our tools a grant finder tool in order
to see if we can help Community
ascertain more funding
projects do take quite a while if to
develop
particularly if all the sources of
funding have not been identified
as some of the members who are in the
chamber today those on the joint member
panel they will probably recall that we
have brought some cases in which don't
exactly fit the framework but we have
looked at whether there are principles
or
approaches that we can use which would
unlock
a tranche of things going forward and in
the fourth review I can tell you that we
we don't do repairs and maintenance but
what we did do in a in false framework
fourth review of the framework was that
we brought in environmental improvements
to parishes or Community halls and that
has brought us forward a whole tranche
of uh new projects that we are either
working with or that we are taking
forward to land in order to deal with
environmental improvements to Village
Halls that previously wouldn't have been
uh acceptable uh to my knowledge we
haven't refused any sillbed at all if
it's outside the framework then we would
talk about the fact with the community
about why that was and we would look at
was there anything else we could help
with so there have been some changes to
the framework year on year which allow
things to open up and for new bids to
come forward and we are working either
with outstanding Silvers which have made
or with emerging bids as they're coming
forward on that basis thank you
add to that
um I think the the other thing that you
have to understand is that there is a
tremendous amount of help offered by
Christine and her team
um and it may well take some time for a
project to actually get all of its ducks
in a row find all of its other funding
and bring a project forward so I think
it was and Christine can correct me if
I'm wrong here I think it was over three
years from Christine's first involvement
with an initial inquiry to the delivery
of the extension of Preston Village Hall
it was a big scheme for them it was kind
of a bit delayed because of the covid
issues but it's often it was certainly
over two years wasn't I think it was
about three years that that actually sat
with Christine and the team before they
eventually got the final bid approval
and and got the scheme delivered
hey yes Council Holt yeah just pick it
up on this topic Christine mentioned
about repairs I think the
councilor about it might press this is
an example of what you're looking at
an application goes in
for a new roof rigidish Hall
part of a Redevelopment with the village
hall and is approved
yet another Village Hall that's pretty
much fallen down needs a new roof
doesn't get funding
I mean that's the sort of example to me
that doesn't make sense because
perhaps an extension is going on one it
gets a complete roof
because there's not an extension on the
other it doesn't really help
I think that's the sort of example that
to me
to me seems unfair within the district
they're both religious they're both
valuable to those communities they're
both needed by those by those
communities but they can't achieve the
same sort of funding
through silk that's an example that I
think is possibly one that is a good one
okay I don't know the two the two um
examples that you
've but the basic principle
is our
framework
that we will not entertain bids for
straight maintenance repair
and the reason for that is that we're
collecting silk connected it's it's as a
result of growth and it's provide the
necessary infrastructure to support that
growth so it should be additional
um there are circumstances where
um I suppose you're identifying a bit of
a gray area where you could say what
we're doing is an improvement it is
additional because we're putting on
solar panels because we're insulating
the roof we're actually making the
infrastructure better and more usable
but in terms of of simple repairs and
maintenance
that wouldn't be eligible through our
bidding process but it would be eligible
for an application to a parish council
for neighborhood sale it's one of the
things that neighborhood still is there
for really the decision is within the
community
so that they they can put that money
into the infrastructure that they think
they need and they may do that as as a
as a part of a collaborative spend
through a bid so that we will provide
some money and the the Paris will
provide some money but if you remember
before we had seal and we had section
106 contributions that were defined at
the time that a planning application
approved
we in those days we heard from
communities saying where's the
infrastructure and the answer was well
there was a contribution to to schools
education there was a contribution to
libraries there were contributions here
and there but I said but what we need is
a new bus shelter or what we need is an
extension to the main tool so
big advantage of what we do with cell is
that we can actually control those funds
and we can Target the communities that
actually want to provide the new
infrastructure and a lot of them that
have had growth will have large amounts
of neighborhood still so I
Joe will probably confirm if I'm wrong
here I think there are eight parishes
that have actually received over a
hundred thousand pounds in neighborhood
still that's over a hundred thousand
pounds has gone to Paris Council funds
for them to to provide or maintain
infrastructure in their communities and
that can include in you know just board
it can include maintenance to the
Village Hall there are all sorts of
things and I I don't know the highest
but it's a is it approaching three
hundred thousand to 200 something
thousand pounds I think for long Melford
Joe might never just confirmed that
yeah so from income collected for still
to date for the neighborhood portion
along Milford got the most at 320
000 pounds
thank you are there any other questions
counselor Hinton
thank you madam chairman
um I'm glad that they follow my rule of
three sheets of two sheets of A4 because
he's got 150 odd Pages here
um there's an awful lot of information
I've managed to Wade through quite a lot
of it and it seems to me that there are
some areas where
our communication could be improved as
to what is actually
done with the money or when people apply
for money what whether they think that
the community thinks that it's what's
needed as well and I take the example
for instance of East Burke old high
school
who are looking for half a half a
million to extend the sports and
recreation facilities available for the
community use
well how do we find out from the
community what they want have they
spoken to the parish council has it all
been sorted out as to what is actually
required or is it just going to take
money away using a Sports Council Etc as
well to help top up that money
from other organizations like the lawn
tennis club or the Bowls Club or the
football club
so I think we need a better
communication strategy in terms of
involving the communities in these
applications because if I'm the only one
who finds them by looking through 150
odd sheets of paper then you can bet
that most of the videos I haven't seen
it either and and also moving on from on
that but on a similar sort of vein
um
360 370
000 pounds for and uh
bring sites for rubbish
uh I think
most people would say that they pay
their council tax to the county to
include rubbish disposal collection by
The District Council yes disposable by
the county why is it being paid for
again via this especially when some of
it is for Portman road walk in Ipswich
somebody agreeing to take your rubbish
all the way into Ipswich from from baber
I know from my particular Ward we take
it into the Essex
when we can we have a bit of difficulty
at the moment because Essex County
councils
it's they've sorted it now but it took a
while to get it sorted that they
wouldn't accept our postcodes when it
came to booking a spot
as their system was up the creek but
anyway that's that's what that one's
water under the bridge but it's
if it's going to be environmentally
friendly these bring sites have got to
be closed to where the rubbish is
generated
that there is money for extension to or
expansion Etc in Sudbury and Ipswich but
leaves out Hadley in the middle seems a
little bit uh strange and I just asked
for some clarification as to what
happens there especially when you see
there's another item in here when I can
find it where there's something like 200
odd million or something that's coming
from all the councils surrounding
Ipswich to help improve the road
structure and the road Network in the
middle of Ipswich
well if we're giving them building all
the houses and giving them all the
business then surely they should be able
to take that from business rates which
goes off to the Suffolk leaders group
and take it from there rather than it
being spent perhaps on the group
improving a rail Junction at Newmarket
just a thought
through Aussie I think there were some
questions in there
I was frantically trying to make some
notes so that I got all of the different
questions
um I think that there's an answer that
addresses
of what councilor Hinton was asking um
and I think that's around the
identification of um
project as a result of growth so they're
not something that we come up with so if
you get and funnily enough he's picked
up on a couple on the outside of Ipswich
which is quite a good example so we have
growth
um Woolsey Grange
and that's going to generate a need at
let's say
the household wasting I think he's
talking about household waste and
recycling centers who referred to bring
sites but I think you're talking about
the house operation recycling centers
which are indeed a county responsibility
the the point is though that our growth
is on the edge of Ipswich and those
people will use that site so it's
reasonable enough to secure a
contribution we won't pay for a new site
but we might make a contribution because
we we use that so I might come to
Christine in a minute um just to say how
that works it's all to do with how
Kristen and her team are talking about
um the the necessary facilities the
other thing that I think you've got to
understand is that some of the things
that you've been referring to
um are in our infrastructure delivery
plan so they're not things that we are
saying yes we're going to um to be
funding this
there's an amount in there for the total
cost of the project there's a column and
I haven't got it in front of me but
there's a column about
um how soon that's likely to be
delivered so it's sort of
list so we might well be talking about
things that are not going to be provided
for four five six years but it's really
important that we know what the the big
spends are on the
on that because we've been so lucky so
far that we've been collecting seal and
we haven't been spending it so I I think
people are running away with the idea
that we've got lots and lots of money
and we're not giving it to anybody but
there are some big spends coming our way
for things like School extensions
previously as I mentioned earlier on
they would have been secured through
section 106 education contributions as
you know um but they're not anymore so
those big spends now come through the
sill process and it's quite important
that they're identified in the
infrastructure delivery plan so that we
know what's coming forward so we Kristen
and her team go to the County Council
they've got the numbers for growth and
those numbers quite simply spell the
additional need for school places or for
libraries or libraries we're including
that
um so I that's sort of a general answer
um I'm not sure if I made any other
notes of any other question that you
asked
um
no I don't think so
um so I don't know Kristen if you can
add a little bit of detail to perhaps
the way that you've talked to
um the various
um other councils infrastructure
providers just to provide all that
detail it's not if I'm honest really a
question about the framework which is
what I'm asking you to approve today
it's a question about all of the
background information that we've given
you but I'm sure Christine's got an
answer a detailed answer
thank you I think reference has been
made to appendix e which is the
infrastructure list this is an important
document
it comprises all the councils projects
largely but not wholly contained in the
infrastructure delivery planners you as
you'll be aware that is the
evidence-based document that underpins
the joint local plan as members will
know because it's it's been said sill is
collected for growth
so the Project's listed in appendix e
flow from the work the collaborative
work that we do with the infrastructure
providers say for instance rail or in
this case with waste uh Suffolk County
Council linked growth we're also talking
to our neighboring authorities uh as
councilor arthi has said there is
development happening close to
boundaries and there are impacts from
placing new residents close to those
boundaries because instead of trekking
back into our districts to use our
facilities they may go into Ipswich and
members may be aware that still can be
spent uh
outside our district boundaries where it
would benefit our residents there are
some caveats to that in the cell
expenditure framework so they have to be
collaborative bids are
a proportion not for total cost and in
this particular case yes we are talking
to Ipswich Borough Council and will
continue our conversations and we would
be expecting section 106 money to be
brought to the table because they are
not yet are still charging Authority I
don't know Tom if you want to add
anything
through you chair and I think yes you've
referenced appendix C the estimates and
forecasts from those infrastructure
providers going to the point where you
were
um
suggesting that greater engagement and
communication with local places and
areas would be a useful function as part
of allocating any seal funds that is
part of what would happen if and when a
seal bid is actually formed and the
County Council come to us and say we
want to extend eastberg or high school
we want to provide sports facilities
that provide for the wider Community
then the response from Christine and her
team would be back to the County Council
okay now start some dialogue with both
the high school and the local community
so that you're able to provide us with
evidence that there is need for that
Community infrastructure and that there
is a desire locally for that to be
provided so I think
at the point at which you see those
estimates from the infrastructure
delivery plan those conversations
haven't necessarily happened but in
respect of the sale expenditure
framework those conversations and that
that local dialogue to understand local
need and want for shared facilities
would come through that end of the
process
okay
thank you councilor Hinton that's uh
you've received quite a lengthy answer
there has that answered your questions
it's answered it's answered most of them
um I think it would be more than two
pages probably but um
the infrastructure delivery plan was
mentioned and I must admit
that documents attached
a taxable plan for the simple reason it
seems to change by the week
let's go on to it and off it without any
sort of run or Reason
uh I'm content to Wade through the
paperwork a bit more and keep in touch
with facility
thank you councilor Hinton any further
questions
before we move over to debate
any further questions
right so there doesn't appear to be any
further questions so now we'll move to
debate councils will only be allowed to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be timed
would anyone like to open the debate
councilor Parker
thank you and I'll be brief because I
think we um it's not really a lot to not
support on this so I'm fairly sure um
that they'll it'll receive member
support but I just want to pick up on a
point that um councilor Hinton made
there with regards to communication on a
very basic level as well
um I think it's incumbent upon all of us
here and of course you know we might we
might not be here but for those that are
returned um after my I think it's really
important that we as uh elected
representatives as
um you know as uh local Champions that
we work with our parishes I think that
we are the first point of call when it
comes to communication so for example
how many of us uh in as counselors are
working with our parishes to help them
formulate their their Pips their Parish
infrastructure plans and actually
understanding or helping those
communities understand how they can
um how they can spend this money this is
eye-watering some money that are coming
because
um councilor Arthur is is absolutely
right the charge always
um is that you know infrastructure isn't
provided with element and of course by
its nature those parishes that have the
most amount of money are those parishes
that have received the most amount of
development which doesn't always sit
easy with those with those communities
that's understood
um but this is such a beneficial thing
for our for our communities that I think
that you know if any of us get an
opportunity to go on to that working
panel grasp it with both heads because
it really helps you understand that
framework so I should be supporting uh
and I should be quiet thank you
McLaren thank you
thank you madam chairman
um I would like to just reiterate which
councilor Arthur mentioned were the
parish liaison meetings that were held
by Christina staff I think I attended
one of the benefit to parachutes was
amazing and I think as Ward members we
should be encouraging our parishes to
attend those because it is a complex for
anybody dealing with cell but parishes
do need the advice but the parish
liaison meetings were absolutely
excellent and we must thank Christine's
staff for doing a good job thank you
thank you Council McLaren
anyone else would like to speak
so if there are no more people wishing
to join the debate
um we'll now move on to the vote I'll
now ask the corporate manager governance
and Civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for councilors to cast their vote
okay cancer beer can I take your vote
please and four
and councilor Newman
um chair that is 27 votes for
thank you that is unanimous
thank you we'll now move on to item 11.
uh paper BC
2249 draft joint local plan enforcement
planning enforcement plan 2023
I would like to invite councilor arthi
to introduce this item and move the
recommendations councilor arthi
I've left all of these things till the
last minute
um so you will see from your papers that
I'm presenting this on behalf of the
planning enforcement task and finish
group
so firstly some background
the existing joint local planning
enforcement plan
this is a bit of a mouthful by the way
but there's a reason for that and that
is that if we have one of these and we
don't have to have one one but if we do
it has to comply with government speak
about what it's called so it's the joint
local planning enforcement plan
so the existing one was adopted in 2017
a process of service transformation in
planning enforcement started in early
2020.
this has included process mapping and
efficiency review using Vizio software
and development and the introduction of
a suite of consistent uniform software
actions and templates you can tell I'm
reading that out because I'm really not
familiar with all of these systems
Enterprise case management software
already used in the development
Management Service has also been brought
into day-to-day use by the team
in December 2020 following a report on
the enforcement service joint overview
and scrutiny committee instructed the
chief planning officer to establish a
joint member officer task group
to review and make recommendations on
the joint well can I say jlpep
having regards the best practice and
other examples of good practice
The Joint member working group first met
in May 2022
the group reviewed other examples it's
quite an important bit really we
reviewed other examples of good practice
in planning enforcement policies at
other councils including Ashford
West northamptonshire Red Bridge and
Milton Keynes
the group also considered what good
practice for baber and mid-suffolk
should look like
members from across both councils
attended the working group meetings
along with myself for councilors Byrne
Stringer Guthrie and field from
mid-suffolk and councilors Busby and
Ward from baber
my thanks to all of them for their
valuable input to help put together the
proposals in front of you today
if I can move on to the key features and
changes
the new plan comprises a policy and a
prioritization strategy
the policy document sets out an
explanation of the principles behind
planning enforcement activity
in order to more transparently explain
how investigations are considered
prioritization strategy details the
factors and weighting that will be given
to different matters through the course
of an investigation
for clarity a simplified investigation
process map showing the typical stages
of an investigation is included
policy summarizes and explains our
approach to planning enforcement
what it is and what it is not
and what is and is not a breach of
planning control so it explains how
suspected breaches should be reported
for investigation
the policy refers to the prioritization
strategy and process map to explain how
reports will be investigated
the current policy filters reports into
three categories high medium or low
the new policy stream size streamlines
this into two categories where the
breach is a planning matter into high
priority which is a site visit within
three working days or a standard
priority which is a site visit within 10
working days
the policy also describes the test of
expediency and this is a word that
featured quite a lot in the talk
the test of expediency which the council
must Undertake and what will happen if
the council does or does not decide to
proceed with formal action
the policy explains how the council will
communicate with members of the public
and other interested parties
the prioritization prioritization
strategy explains the approach to
scoring reports suspected breaches by
type harm and impact
which will guide how cases will be
investigated
as this is a new approach to
investigation
it is recommended that this is reviewed
by The Joint member officer working
group after 12 months
that's to ensure that it is effective
efficient and ensures cases causing
unacceptable planning harm are
appropriately investigated
so I'm proposing the recommendations as
per your papers there is a slight change
I think to the papers so 6.1 is that the
draft joint local planning enforcement
plan I think it says policy in your
papers that should be planned
2023 the jlpep set out at appendix a be
adopted and published on the council's
website
the director of Planning and Building
control we authorized to make any
necessary consequential amendments to
finalize and publish the jlp and I think
one of those is at page 216
second bullet point of the second and
the second sentence I think there's
carry over there from drafting so if
anybody got to that page and read that
bit and thought that shouldn't be there
well done
um
so
finally that the 6.3 finally that the
policy be reviewed by a joint member
working group within 12 months of its
implementation so this is kind of
ensuring that if we have got anything a
little bit wrong and it doesn't work
quite right that this can be reviewed
similar to the principles to the cell
framework a little bit of suck it and
see if we have problems with it if any
of it is not working we commit ourselves
to review it within 12 months
gentlemen
let's throw Aussie can I have a second
of please
councilor Alliston crawl
now we can move to questions counselors
may ask as many questions as they wish
because they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question who would like to start the
questions
councilman Karen
thank you mother and German
this subject is as important to parish
councils as the previous subject was
can I ask if there are any plans
to once this is adopted any plans to
work with Parish councils in liaison
um meetings or
online training okay
um no but it's a great idea so I'm
looking towards Phil Isbell who helped
compile all of this and I'm very much
hoping that he will agree that we ought
to be able to do some town and Parish
briefings to explain it to them
did you want to talk thank you through
YouTube yes we we do believe that it's
it's a change that we'll need
appropriate training of Parish councils
in uh in the coming months so we will be
looking to do that so that they
understand both the way the process
works and can explain it to their
parishioners with some ease one hopes
chairman just to add to that also the
new members that come in well any return
members or new members it would be
useful to have that training session to
include councilors as well
thank you yes Council McLaren did you
have first I did have a further question
Madam chairman thank you very much
um I think we need to know this is a
an increase in work for the family law
enforcement team
do we have the resources within the
department to deal with this effectively
thank you
um that isn't really a question for me
it falls under Phil Isbell and his team
um so I'll ask him to answer that I very
much hope the answer is yes
through you chairman um we now have a
full team which was not the case for the
past three years so we have now a
compliment of Staff they are all trading
and therefore to that extent we are in a
process of staff development and growing
our own as it were I think it's
therefore my view that we are going to
have to invest some time in training up
more Junior officers so that they gain
experience on difficult cases but over
time my opinion is we will have the
resource that we need to do the job I
don't feel there's a need at this stage
to ask for further resource to
accomplish this but clearly whilst we're
in a process of training we are going to
have put some of our time into educating
and informing officers who have come to
the planning enforcement profession from
other areas
thank you thank you madam
thank you councilor John Osborne
yeah thank you madam chairman actually I
was going to ask the same question
you've beaten into it
um because obviously
um councilor arthi referred to um
priority cases that there would be a
site visit within three working days
which is quite an Ask actually so I do
hope there are going to be sufficient
resources in place
um it's not moral question it's just I
think you've copied and pasted on
um appendix a
on page 216
on the second bullet point you've got is
this the right turn please sorry that
that was the example I was giving of
something that will have to be sorry can
I stand at the same time that was the
example I was giving I'd identified one
particular
error
that was from the drafting process so if
somebody had somebody had put
Ty the right term or is this the right
wording or something and obviously that
will be taken out well spotted excellent
shows I'm doing my homework
homework thank you councilor Simon
Barrett uh yeah um I totally agree about
the trading I think it's really key on
uh enforcement because I think there is
certainly from Parish councils I think
they think that everything is very easy
to enforce and the council has many uh
of ammunition in his locker actually
it's the other way around and I think
the managing expectation of parish
councils is something that we should do
so I think that's a good point Mary I
think
um my experience of that has been I'm
sure all of you have sitting in a parish
meeting and people expecting baby to
come along with a boot and kick
something out which is not great because
as we know uh the applicants and the
planning laws all very gray so that
that's a good point my other point
um
uh
yes I I sort of get lost sometimes
especially on the last meeting of the
last Council of are we in a debate or
questions and we do merge we're in
questions absolutely I'm trying to get
so we don't have to have a debate
um
so um on page two three one
appendix C
um I think that's a very good diagram
it's or the flow of where the um the uh
how the process works I think that's
quite good it's good to see what I'm
just querying and this is sort of my
question I think I know the answer
because you never ask a question unless
you know the answer do you counselor
arthy
um
so am I thinking that in the officer
stage obviously the administration says
you've got your three working days to
get those into that point the officer
stage it looks to me like the maximum
time is 40 38 days would I be correct
because you've got high two working
three work
three working days
medium 10 working days at one point then
you've got your consultation period 28
days and then that would be the end of
that period is that right so the maximum
on that is
would be I think uh called my Mass
probably 28 days
would anyone like to confirm sorry 38 38
days sorry 38 days
yeah Phil as well thank you gem through
you um
I think it's important to remember that
that workflow is a typical workflow
rather than a specific case expectation
there is a more detailed version of this
which officers use and are developing a
set of performance measures against but
for the purposes of a public document
which members can share with their
parishes and can discuss as need be this
is designed to set out what a typical
investigation would take it is not
expected to be an absolute guarantee
that each case will follow that nor is
it appropriate to share greater detail
lest that cause Mischief on the part of
those who might seek to cause Mischief
so our perspective as officers and I
haven't sat down and calculated the
number of days specifically is that what
you see within the policies within the
plan forgive me is intended to set out a
generalized expectation and that there
will be communication with the ward
member about the details of that as the
process is followed and you can see
various contact points through that
workflow which are expected to provide
updates to counselors about the progress
of the investigation and clearly as we
say within the plan that will need to be
tailored to the specific matter being
investigated
so clearly it's not just Parish councils
that need their time and things managing
or their expectations managed in his
councils as well importantly this
counselor
uh councilman crawl
on reflection and mine wasn't a question
more for debate I'll hold it back
councilor Hinton
thank you madam chairman just a quick
Point looking at the the workflow and
the uh the various papers that come with
it one of the areas which seems to be
unrepresented and I'd like the officers
to explain it if this is the case or not
and that is a time frame around getting
a response from legal because it seems
to be the standard
response at the moment is
with legal I'm waiting for them to come
back we know that a lot of it goes via
the shared legal partnership at
Barrington
ever they're always complaining that
they're overworked and all the rest of
it but do we build any of that to worry
about expertise into our own legal
representation here in baber
absolutely well I think that's a really
good question and a lot of us I think
have been it might be everybody in this
room I don't know has been frustrated
when things get stuck with legal for
quite a while I don't know if Philly's
Bell can give us an answer as to what
measures he has what sort of tools he
has to speed up legal response
chairman through you the the situation
with legal is that hopefully the amount
of times and cases in which you'll need
legal advice are relatively small and
the officers within the team should from
within the skills in the team and from
my planning colleagues in my team I
managed to deal with any straightforward
legal questions rather than the more
complicated ones inevitably when you get
to the point of serving a notice or
following a prosecution those are more
complicated points where you need to
allow the right time for lawyers to get
involved but they are they are a small
proportion of cases and and therefore
the workflow does not accommodate or
particularly provide for the time taken
by other people who might contribute to
it and and it could well be that other
professional bodies might need to be
might need to be asked for advice in
relation to an influence of matter
highways is one perhaps flooding might
be another and so to that extent legal
advice is not a particular factor which
we think would affect the way that the
workflow is processed although I
understand that in many cases told that
it
the lawyers is an unsatisfactory answer
thank you are there any further
questions
oh yes councilor arthi well it's it's a
further answer really to one of the
earlier questions or a comment on um
the question from councilor Barrett I
think the important thing here is that
we spell out to all parties that's the
the person who might be doing something
that needs enforcement and the person
who's complaining about what it is that
they think needs enforcing so that's all
parties and we need to spell out to all
parties what they what they should and
what they hopefully can expect of us
the flowchart that you referred to was
something that we picked up from the
authorities that we looked at
and the group thought that it was
particularly helpful and so we tried to
use it we had to modify it to fit
because you can't just Nick somebody
else's flowchart and we're fairly
hopeful that it will be useful both to
the people making the complaint to the
person who's having a complaint against
them and to the team who actually have
to enforce whatever they can with regard
to
um to what's happened so we thought that
was particularly helpful but I I do take
your point and it applies to the whole
plan that if it throws up difficulties
we will review within 12 months
are there any further questions
if there are no further questions we'll
move on to debate councilman crawl would
you like to open the debate please if I
could um and it's because I've seconded
the motion and there's a very specific
reasons why I have you'll notice the
first thing is that the report itself
the one the recommendations we're voting
upon are just that they're a broad
description I think the and this is
something we have needed for a long time
in the eight years I've been here I've
heard members across all sides of the
chamber
using the word complaining is harsh but
that's actually the meanest strength of
it because nobody's had any certainty
there has been no understanding of how
enforcement is carried out or in many
members View
not forced out because we don't know the
criteria on which it's based here we
have the criteria and I just draw
attention to the fact that not only is
it needed this provides a structure I
take a particular interest because this
is an identified risk as part of our
risk management
um and it's described and I would draw
members attention
not that it's what we are discussing but
that's the meat and
the bones in the meat of it is that
appendix a b and c the plan the strategy
behind it and of course the flowchart
that's going to be the sort of thing
that we as members
if we're back we'll be able to look at
and maybe to make an assessment with
when we're discussing a potential
enforcement case with any officers in
planning enforcement so I really welcome
this and as I say I I identify this
we've all identified this as a risk and
it's on the risk register and uh and so
it should be so I'm going to be
supporting this thoroughly thank you
very much
thank you councilman craw
would anyone else like to speak
if there's no one else then we'll move
on to the boat
um
so I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for councilors to cast their vote cancer
beer can I take your vote please for
what and cancer Noom
thank you
councilor Melanie Barrett are you have
can I take your vote oh it's just in
lovely thank you
chair that is 27 4.
thank you so that is curry councilor
asked me I'm sure you'd like to rest
your voicemail
thank you chairman and I'll have the
chocolate
thank you good enjoy
moving on to item 12.
paper BC 2250
special urgent decisions taken by
officers under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution
I would like to invite the chief
executive to introduce this report
thank you
thank you chairman and good evening
councilors I'll be extremely brief as
you know where matters or decisions are
made outside of formal council meetings
for reasons urgency or exempt from
calling then they have reported back to
the next available full council meeting
for noting in this particular case
you'll see the decision within the
papers that was made the reason being it
related to funding received by
government with
time scales under which they had to be
delivered and as a result it wasn't
possible to take it through the normal
mechanisms and so urgent decision was
made hence reporting it back to you this
evening thank you councilors
thank you so unless anyone has any
questions that was for noting
great
so item 13
paper BC
2251 council's parental leave policy
I would like to invite Council Ward to
introduce this item and move the
recommendation Council Ward thank you
chairman
uh castles will know that we don't yet
have a parental leave policy for
councilors so that there's no
entitlement to maternity eternity shared
parental or adoption lead now there's no
legal entitlement for councilors to have
this but it is possible for us to adopt
a policy and indeed when we consider the
independent remuneration panels report
back in October there was a
recommendation to creating parental
leave policy within that report
and so consequently this evening we've
got a draft policy here to consider it's
based on the LGA model policy so similar
to the policies that are being adopted
around the country
now you may think looking around the
council
why do we need to parental leave policy
but
the point is
we do need to make public office more
accessible to a much wider range of
individuals individuals rather than just
those of us who have retired and got
time on our hands
and so we do need to increase that
diversity
um age experience and background and so
this is one of the small things we can
do to help with without diversity so
therefore I do want to propose the
recommendation that we approve the
adoption of the policy that you'll see
at appendix a in the report thank you
and I'd like to as I say please
thank you Council are you suck a dick
yeah I'm happy to Second this and um we
we actually in Sudbury and Council
Lindsay will know we have a a young
mother County councilor who has been
bringing her baby to council meet he's
managed to stop certain speakers in
their tracks
but you know it is there um people do
need it and it is really encouraging to
be able to get younger people we all
suffer
looking around here Grecian 2000 the
sales are excessive in Sudbury in
council chambers but we do need to
encourage younger people and we need to
make it easier for them to access coming
to councils and be able to be
accountable
um so this is something that we should
all uh
really Embrace and you know we are now
on the election Trail and we're all
looking for younger people
please come forward
that's an advertisement for everyone not
just the conservatives but everyone
so I do support them by the way
thank you councilor Barrett
um can I
um can we move now to questions has
anyone got a question
cannot ask as many questions as you like
Council Melanie Barrett
um thank you very much a practical
aspect to it
um what is what are the arrangements for
the cover if the person is off for six
months
um especially if they're a member of the
cabinet will there be someone sort of
able to to provide that for residents
that was exactly my concern too so I'm
glad you've asked that Council award
yeah um there are as you'll see in the
policy in Section 5 50 paragraphs
do talk about
um uh you know Council has been able to
nominate other councilors to to cover or
discuss with political group leaders so
the policy does have Provisions for
arranging councilors cover within that
period but obviously yes um if it's a
Cabinet member then the duties are quite
considerable a lot more so than for
Backpage counselors but that that will
have to be worked out in the
negotiations for for that cover but um
policy does does cater for that
councilor Hinton
thank you I was looking very carefully
at the 4.5 first bullet point
um wondering who my designated carer was
going to be but
hopefully I can dodge that for a little
bit longer but I was just a bit
concerned uh it's a general question as
much as anything else is it rather
generous to be spending the electorates
money by giving both allowances and
special responsibility pay for somebody
who's not there
should if they're not doing the special
responsibility job that they've been
giving the extra money for surely that
should go to whoever's standing in for
them or just not be given to anybody it
just seems strange that we're going to
give them extra money for like 20
. Council award can you answer that
please so
are you suggesting then that if somebody
takes parental leave then their
remuneration disappears and that's not
the whole purpose of this is they can
still be remunerated
just this
so you just get the basic counselor
remuneration well we uh that's not part
of this the the
um the intention is that uh however an
individual is remunerated that
remuneration will continue through the
uh belief period
that's not what it says
yes it does
yeah it says where a replacement
Council Lindsay have you got a question
as well I think it was just in response
to councilor hinton's question does it
not say in the um
I think it's saying that the person
where you allocate someone else to take
over from you they get the special
responsibility allowance of our main
misreading that that's on page 243
Council Ward I might have to um refer to
uh to get some officer support on this
but it it does say that the person
taking over will get the SRO but it
doesn't say the person on leave would it
does where does it say that 3.1 check
right
sorry can I just clarify it does it does
mean that both and the idea is actually
that the person who's taking the
maternity leave is not put at any
disadvantage so there will be a cost to
the council but it is considered to be
minimal
yes so so they can they so they continue
to receive their allowance and the other
person gets the allowances
councilman crawl
is it not the case or would it not be
the case under that special
responsibility allowance question that
that option would exist in fact it does
at any time in terms of committee
placements and SRA placements for
example the cabinet positions are in the
gift of the leader and if an individual
felt that they just wanted to have their
regular allowance and not take their SRA
they would have that option all we're
saying is we're not going to
deliberately take it away from them is
that a fair statement
yes chair that is fair and Cancers of
course have the discretion to refuse any
allowance that they don't wish to take
up
um can I ask a question
um does should we be extending this to
or does it already extend to carers and
other
people who have particular
responsibilities
oh it is they covers that
doesn't you know caring for elderly
people
chair this is a prevental leave policy
so they certainly would cover the carer
in this instance is the parental carer
the ordinary remuneration allowance
gives the ability for people who are
carers to be able to claim an allowance
when they are caring for their
dependents or relatives to be able to
attend Council meetings so the provision
is already in that um I uh the
remuneration allowance for councilors
thank you councilor Hinton doesn't this
effectively mean that this policy is
ageist
Chad this is
chair this is just literally to cover
for paternity maternity leave adoption
and the other permutations that come
with that if you to look at uh dependent
carers allowance then we would need to
to take that away and look at it but
this is solely for Parental care
are there any other questions yes
councilor Parker yeah I think you check
it it is in the report but for the
benefit of anybody that's listening
could you confirm or clarify that there
is still an expectation for counselors
to attend at least one meeting every six
months please
yes chair so there is still a legal
requirement for for councils to attend
six months but of course there is if
there was maternity there would be
dispensation for cancer you wouldn't
have to we could Grant dispensation
any further questions
yes councilor Busby
does this apply to people who become
eligible during their term
or
does it apply to people who are
in the position before their term
before the term starts
four months four years
what I'm thinking is that that somebody
could
say
decide
that will be
come a counselor
apply immediately for Parental leave
take 12 months off get paid all that
answers and then resign
how they knew that before they became a
counselor if they've already become one
and they've done something and then it
happens during it then it's a difference
so chair just to say that if the the
abuse the only way they could use it is
to actually be pregnant or adopt or
foster a child so that's that's quite an
extreme but the flexibility is there so
it is reviewed after six months with the
option to extend that to 52 weeks so
there is a there is a a time in the
middle of that where it would be
reviewed so it wouldn't be just a
straightforward 12 months and that you
get paid and as I say it's rather
extreme to see somebody abusing the
system by having a baby or or adopting
it that would be extreme for the amount
of allowance that you get I just remind
you I am in charge of the budget
surely surely depending upon timing it
is quite possible that somebody might
get elected without having knowledge of
their pregnancy
so I don't think we can be prescriptive
here
Council Melanie Barrett
it's an unlikely scenario but you if
this is successful you could have a huge
intake of young females into this
Council and you could be in quite an
awkward position
um I suspect so
it'd be where what you wishful
any further questions
councilor arthi just comment really I'm
looking around the room and I think
the only person here became a parent
whilst he was a counselor
well you've got your allowance and you'd
be able to have a year off
but I've been told it doesn't reply
retrospectively
it might have been a while ago as well
laughs
um
have you gone into debate I'm not sure
whether we've gone into debate already I
bet does anyone want to add anything or
shall we finish oh councilor Lindsay
oh just just to say I support this
um but I don't and just to um
councilor Barrett
um the bigger problem is is
um the the size of the amount and the
time that's required for a young parent
to to be a counselor
so I think I think important to address
that particular issue and I think I mean
and another thing that shocks me is the
the smallness of the allowance that at
our leader has I mean it's a full-time
job and it's getting the pay of a you
know for a part-time
sort of worker you know I just don't
know
I think that's a bigger problem to be
honest
um for for all for all councilors
and I think I've been ill and I was off
for some time
and I had to I did arrange for for other
counselors to do my my work but I think
um people don't realize that we're we're
not it's not a full-time job it's
supposed to be do a full-time 24 7. and
the amount the allowance that we get
unless you are a leader or a Cabinet
member
is reflects the fact that it's a
part-time part-time position but I think
for young people
it's not enough to
thank you thank you chair that is
showing in blue for cancers to cast
their vote
it's not a beer
oh it's gone
and councilman Newman right
councilor Lindsay are you having
technical problems
um four thank you
Norman
um not not a question or anything really
just mentioned that I'm gonna have to
leave the meeting if that's all right
and to just let you know thank you
that's nice
chair that is 24 votes four and one
abstention
thank you that is carried
item 14 paper BC 2252
paid policy statement
2023-24 I would like to invite
councilwar to introduce this item and
move the recommendations cast award
thank you chairman as counselors will be
aware and are set out in the report the
council is legally required to adopt a
pay policy statement each year
a post statement for 2023-24 is set up
an appendix a
following the decisions made by Council
in March last year a statement has been
updated to reflect the salary and job
title changes made to the directors and
deputy chief executive
no changes are proposed to 2023-24
. finally for information as explained
in paragraph 3.5 of the report the
castles have now published their gender
pay gap for 2022 on the website
I therefore propose the recommendations
2.1 at the proposed pay policy statement
for 2023-24 has set up section three be
approved and 2.2 that publication of the
council's gender pay Gap asset 31st of
March 2022 be noted
let's have a second please
thank you can I have a second at Council
Barrett
so today I would like to um
any questions
so no questions I'll move to debate
would anyone like to open the debate
so as as there's no questions or debate
we'll move straight to the vote thank
you
I'd like to invite
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office to conduct electronic vote
thank you thank you chair that vote is
now in progress
councilor Lindsay are you still having
problems
oh it's just come through thank you
Council Busby
do you want me to shall I take it
manually thank you
councilor Parker
[Laughter]
thank you
yeah
chair that is 23 votes four and one
abstention
BC 2253 review of joint chief executive
remuneration
this item has been withdrawn
item 16 councilor appointments are there
any changes to placings
you know
[Laughter]
um item 17 emotional native none
received
so whizzing off to the end the next
meeting is the annual council meeting
which as I mentioned before you will all
be invited to
um and it's on Tuesday the 23rd of May
2023 at 5 30 and I wish you all a
time with your electioneering for those
that are partaking
thank you and goodbye